AMY UNRUH: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to an App
Engine Hangout.
So this week, we have with us
Robert, who is an App Engine
Test Engineer, Software
Engineer in Test.
And this is really a great
opportunity to--
he's going to talk about some
of the test beds and test
runners that he uses, and that
you can use as well.
And he's going to talk
a little bit about
what he does too.
So this is a really great window
into the job of one of
the people who helps
App Engine work
as great as it does.
And so I just want to do a
little plug before we switch
to the studio for what's
coming up next week.
We're going to have a
chat with one of our
big App Engine customers.
And we'll announce a little bit
more about that a little
bit later in the week.
OK, and I want to apologize.
We said earlier that we could
invite some people who might
be interested in joining the
Hangout just to chat with us.
But we had some technical
issues.
Sorry, we got started
a little late.
And so we're unfortunately not
able to do that this time,
really wanted to.
And we hope to be able to do
it in future Hangouts.
OK, so let's switch to
the studio, where we
have Robert and Danny.
And what I'd like to do is this
just to get started, just
ask Robert a few questions
about what he does, just
because I think it'd be of
interest to everyone watching.
DANNY HERMES: Hopefully,
you don't catch
him off guard, huh?
AMY UNRUH: Yeah.
No, this is this not
a big grilling.
But I think everyone would be
interested, before we start
with what you actually have
planned to demo, just tell us
a little bit about what you do
in your day-to-day work.
And maybe how a little bit about
how you got started with
it, too, if you think people
would like to hear that.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: OK, so I
joined Google and App Engine
three and a half years
ago as an SET,
Software Engineer in Test.
And my job is basically to write
software that helps with
testing for the three
major user groups.
For one, App Engine
developers--
so people who write App Engine,
to help them make sure
App Engine doesn't break
when we push a new
release, for example--
then the external developers,
like everyone who's watching,
who write applications that
run on App Engine.
And we want to provide tools
so that when you write your
application, you can
test them easily.
And the third group are internal
developers at Google
who also write App Engine
applications.
And they also want to make sure
that the applications
they write are testable.
And because Google has some
special infrastructure, I also
work on making this
infrastructure usable for
tests for App Engine.
DANNY HERMES: So are
you a polyglot in
your day-to-day life?
Are you targeting
every runtime?
Or is it just one specific
runtime?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
Mostly Python.
DANNY HERMES: Mostly Python.
OK.
I knew today, we were mostly
talked about Python.
But I wasn't sure in your day
job in Test, if you're
targeting all the runtimes, or
if you have specialists for
each individual one.
DANNY HERMES: So
we split it up.
We have other Software
Engineers in Test.
Another colleague, Dave
[INAUDIBLE], he writes on
Java, works in Java.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Sure.
Cool.
Back to Amy.
You have some more questions,
I'm sure.
AMY UNRUH: Well, I didn't
want to subject
Robert to a big grilling.
So actually, let's just
start with what he
had planned to demo.
And just for everyone watching,
if we have a little
bit of time at the end, we'll
go to the moderator queue.
So we hope to answer just a few
of your general questions.
And if we have a bit of extra
time at the end, we can also
sort of make this a bit of a
general Office Hours, as well.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: So what I
want to walk through today are
three test tools we use and
also have available for
external developers.
And one of them is
for unit testing.
Then I want to talk about
handler testing, which was
also a question from the page,
the Moderator page.
And then I want to talk about
end-to-end testing, which was
also a question.
How can you test your
whole stack?
And finally, if we have time,
talk about library testing.
If you write libraries for App
Engine, how can you test that?
DANNY HERMES: Right.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: So just
go ahead and do it?
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Can
you see the screen?
Is it big enough?
DANNY HERMES: You probably want
to pump the size up by
one or two.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: OK.
AMY UNRUH: You might want
it a bit bigger.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
DANNY HERMES: Maybe
a couple more.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Wow,
that's going to be--
DANNY HERMES: It will be.
But it's more than 80
characters, right?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
Yeah, let's see.
DANNY HERMES: You can reset your
PS1 to something shorter,
export PS1 equals.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: I'm
going to leave it now.
Otherwise, I mess up my bash
and then maybe not even--
DANNY HERMES: It's just PS1.
You can just close it
and restart bash.
PS1 equals and--
you don't need the
dollar sign.
Well, you don't want that.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
So what do I want?
DANNY HERMES: PS1 equals say,
demo and then dollar sign and
then a space.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
OK, this one died.
Export PS1 equals--
like this?
DANNY HERMES: Well, put
it in quotes and put
a space after it.
Yeah, like that.
It should be fine.
There you go, a lot
more space, right?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Now
I'm getting lost in my
directories, but that's--
OK, so what I want to do--
DANNY HERMES: Whatever.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
Three things.
The first thing--
I think I can increase
that, too--
is the testbed.
Testbed is a library we have for
unit testing and Python in
particular.
There's also an equivalent for
Java that helps you test your
Java applications on
a unit test level.
And unit testing is important
because software, if it's not
trivial, it's made up
of lots of pieces.
And you want to test those
individual pieces because if
you can identify the piece,
the particular piece that
failed, it's easier for you
to debug it and fix it.
So unit testing.
And for Python, it's
called testbed.
For Java, I don't even know if
it has an explicit name.
But you can always just
do a Google search--
or whatever your favorite
search engine is--
App Engine and then
local unit test.
And that will either bring
you to the Python
or to the Java site.
And I'm going to talk
about Python today.
And all the information I'm
going to talk about, you will
also find on this page.
So let's see.
For Python, since I don't
see the path I'm in--
DANNY HERMES: PWD will tell you
the path, if you want it.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
OK, testbed.
So I just set up a demo here.
And I will use a run script
to run the tests.
And the run script is
also available on
the page I just showed.
So you can just download
it and use it.
DANNY HERMES: And what are
you going to be testing?
Just the basic hello world
app or something else?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: No, we're
just going to test
the units of an app.
So we're not going to test an
actual app, but only pieces.
And for App Engine, when you
write an application, you will
use services of App Engine.
You will use Datastore,
Memcache,
[INAUDIBLE], things like that.
And often for unit tests
you want to mock that.
DANNY HERMES: Right,
using stubs or
some other local mock.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Right.
And for App Engine, we now have
this test library that
provides those stubs.
DANNY HERMES: So the
test runner--
are you going to talk
about the app that
you're running it on?
Or are you just going to run it
and talk about how it's--
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
This is just going
to run in the shell.
And I'm going to show you the
tests we have and then how to
run it, and what the
dependencies
are, and how it looks.
DANNY HERMES: Cool.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: OK, so as I
mentioned, we have the test
script, which is
just this one.
Let me set up the path,
PYTHONPATH equals--
and I'll put this.
The test runner, what it does,
it uses unittest2, which is a
Python library, which is similar
to unittest, which is
in the standard library.
But it has extra features like
finding tests in directories.
So what you can do is you
say, give me all the
tests in this directory.
And then it will just go through
the directory and find
all the tests.
So that's why I use unittest2.
And as you can see here, it
expects two input values in
the SDK panel.
So the SDK, the Python App
Engine SDK, you want to use
and the root of the test bed.
DANNY HERMES: Which is
probably just current
directory here.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
Which is, yeah--
and as I mentioned, we have a
couple of dependencies, which
for this case, are unittest2.
I already mentioned that.
And then webtest.
I'm going to talk about
webtest later.
But it's important if you
want to test handlers.
Handlers are the pieces that
actually render the website
and serve it to the user.
So this is also something you
want to make sure that
actually works with the test.
So those are the two
dependencies we have.
And we have tests in the
tests directory.
Here we have three tests--
Datastore, logs, and handlers
for modules for
three types of tests.
And as an example,
I'm just going to
look through the Datastore.
DANNY HERMES: Emacs, man
after my own heart.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
There's a--
AMY UNRUH: Me, too.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: --small
followed by--
DANNY HERMES: All three of us,
Emacs users, wonderful.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: OK, so
what are we going to do?
First, we input unittests.
We say, hey, we want to use
the unittest mode, because
want unittest.
Then we import the modules.
We're going to use the App
Engine services-- in this
case, Memcache, database, db,
and then testbed, which allows
us to use the [? steps ?].
And testbed comes from
the ext package.
In this particular case, we
have a TestModel, which is
just a simple model that has
an IntegerProperty, text
property to hold some data.
And we also have a function
here that's called
GetEntityViaMemcache that if you
retrieve an entity through
that function it will first
look it up in Memcache.
If it's not there--
DANNY HERMES: So
in other words,
what NDB does by default.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Yes.
Now that we have NDB,
we should use NDB.
But it's a good example
for this.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah,
definitely.
Except there's one level of
caching not even included
there, which is the
instance-level cache.
But that's a conversation
for another day.
That's what we're
testing here.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: But
NDB is a nice library.
[? Gigoed ?] is best.
So what do we do?
We write a unittest, the usual
unittest or test case as a
base class.
And then we set up our test.
So default thing is you say,
hey, setUp-- this is what is
done before every single
test you do.
And the counterpart for this
is tearDown, which is done
after every single
test you execute.
DANNY HERMES: So I notice
you have in your setUp,
init_datastore_v3_stub.
Can talk a little bit about
what that v3 is doing?
And how people can know what
stubs and what stub names
correspond to the services
they're going to use?
If you're going to talk about
this later, by all means, hold
off until then.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: I'm
just going to--
we are two steps
away from that.
DANNY HERMES: Oh, OK.
Cool.
We'll wait til then.
We'll wait two steps.
My bad.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: So first
we instantiate a Testbed
object, which is an object that
will create the stubs for
you and then mock out certain
capabilities so you can use
them for testing.
Once you've done that, you
say, hey, activate
the Testbed for me.
This is the step where you say,
whatever has been there
before, save it, so when we
deactivate it later on, you
can restore it.
And then we say init stub.
And we have different
services.
Each service has a name.
And then it's init service
name stub.
So init_memcache_stub's
obvious.
Then there's
init_taskqueue_stub, init_
[? make  ?] stub, and then
datastore_v3_stub, which is
not that obvious.
Why is it v3, right?
So that's--
DANNY HERMES: And was there
a v2, et cetera?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Yeah, it's
just an iteration of the
Datastore versions we had.
And this is v3.
I'm sure at some point
there will be a v4.
Because we don't want to have
you deal with regressions when
we switch to a new dadaists.
We'd rather be explicit--
rather be explicit
than implicit.
DANNY HERMES: So I actually
know a bit of the history
behind the naming there.
I was just--
for the viewers' sake.
But the question more that I
had to ask was how would we
know that from
google.appengine.api.importdb
would correspond to a stub
that's Datastore?
Is there any explicit
way to do this?
Or is it just knowing
what's there?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Two
things you can do.
You either look it up on the
website, which says, hey, here
are all the supported stubs.
Or if you just say, whatever,
I don't care init_all_stubs.
DANNY HERMES: Oh, OK.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: OK.
So that's--
DANNY HERMES: But that will make
the test a little slower
and certainly less
explicit, right?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Yeah.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: So
you can do both.
OK, restored.
Now the first test is really
straightforward.
We just create an entity, put
it into Datastore, and then
try to retrieve two entities.
But the test says, hey, check
that it's only one entity.
And now that we use Testbed and
activate it before every
test run, tearDown after every
test run, we will work on an
empty Datastore.
So this test will actually pass
because no matter how
many times you run it, you
tear down the Datastore,
create a new one.
So that's what it does.
The next test is really just
checking hey, create a key,
delete the entity, see if when
I retrieve that key, I don't
get anything returned.
And this also already uses the
GetEntityViaMemcache function,
which just looks
into Datastore,
and if it finds it--
OK.
Then I'm just going
to skip here.
This one [INAUDIBLE]
entity then retrieves the
entity via Memcache.
And we want to check that's
actually the entity returned
we have created.
So it's just again testing the
path for that function.
DANNY HERMES: Sorry, I don't
want to hijack--
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
No, go ahead.
DANNY HERMES: So I notice one
thing, which made me think.
We have two runtimes supported
in Python--
2.5 and 2.7.
And unittest actually
changed between--
well, it changes every
version of Python.
But there was initially
assertEqual, assertNotEqual,
assertTrue, assertFalse,
and that was about it.
But in 2.7, there were like six
more asserts added, one of
which is assertNone.
Now I see you're doing an
assertEqual with a none.
So is this written with
both runtimes in mind?
Or are there separate test cases
or separate ways you're
going to write it for the
different runtimes?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
So this is really
up to the app developer.
If he says, my app will only run
on Python 2.7 because it's
the future, and Python 2.5 is
going to go away at some
point, you can use the test
functionality that is
available in Python 2.7--
so assertNone and all those
extra fancy features.
DANNY HERMES: But Testbed
itself will run on both.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
Is agnostic, yeah.
It really just uses--
it's really just a utility.
It doesn't depend on unittest.
It will just provide additional
tools for your unit
testing [INAUDIBLE].
DANNY HERMES: Like making
these stubs.
Cool.
Sorry.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
No, that's fine.
Also, Python 2.7 actually
includes unittest2, which I
specifically included
here as a library--
DANNY HERMES: As part of
the standard library.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Yes.
DANNY HERMES: OK, great.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: And then
the last one, the last
function I'm testing here,
or the last piece of
functionality, I create an
entity then get the entity
key, delete that entity,
and see, if I use
GetEntityViaMemcache, it's
still available.
Because GetEntityViaMemcache
is not aware of Datastore
deletes, but it cached it.
It would find it in cache and
then [? return ?] it.
DANNY HERMES: One of the two
hardest problems in computer
science, right-- cache
and [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHING]
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Yeah, so
this is a simple example.
Don't use that in your
application.
DANNY HERMES: Please.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Please.
DANNY HERMES: Pretty,
pretty please.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Yeah, and
so this is what's done.
Now if we--
where are we?
We're here.
If we use the run script and
point it to the SDK, because
that's one of the parameters
and point it into the test
directory, it would go through
all the tests, execute them,
and then this [INAUDIBLE]
what we see here.
DANNY HERMES: Great.
Another side question-- are
you on the newest 1.7.3?
Or are you using 1.7.2?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: That's
actually 1.7.2.
DANNY HERMES: Aw, come on.
If people didn't see, 1.7.3 was
just released yesterday.
So if you haven't upgraded
yet, go ahead and do it.
But apparently we can't
even get our own test
engineers to do it.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Well,
actually, I've worked already
with 1.7.4 but I didn't
want to use it.
DANNY HERMES: Oh!
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Better
to be safe than sorry.
AMY UNRUH: Robert?
Just for fun, why don't you
edit one of those tests to
have an [? inclusion ?] break
and show what it looks like,
if that's the case?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: So we can
just introduce a simple
test_fail--
DANNY HERMES: Contrasting
styles there.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
What do we want?
False.
OK, so we now [INAUDIBLE]
DANNY HERMES: There we go.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: We fail.
And here's what you get--
so just failing test.
And one thing we don't provide
is, for this particular case,
integration into a tool, like
Eclipse or PyDev for Eclipse.
Because often, people have
different sets of tools and
just to support all of
them is really hard.
So we just give you the basics
and then you can hook it up.
DANNY HERMES: And, I mean, as
far as what we're talking
about today, the Python
community isn't necessarily
married to one or a few set
of tool [? chains ?].
There's--
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: [INAUDIBLE]
tests, for example.
DANNY HERMES: Right.
So we live in harmony
in that way.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Another
thing I wanted to talk about,
and there was also
a question--
how can you test webapp2?
Webapp2 is a library, again,
that runs on App Engine and
helps you to render
HTTP response.
DANNY HERMES: And create WSGI
handlers and things.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Yes.
So let's have a look at this.
What we have--
a simple handler here that uses
webapp2 and does nothing
other than writing header word
and setting the content type.
So it's really simple.
If you run that in your app--
DANNY HERMES: It's the Python
2.7 hello, world.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
Hello, world.
And what you also see here,
we use testbed because we
want to test it.
And that's actually--
ignore that.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: This
is the test part.
We're going to use webtest.
And the test itself again
is just a [? check ?]
class of test case.
And then in the setUp, we first
create the app, the WSGI
app, we're going to test, which
is the handler we have
and then some path that works.
And then we use webtest2.
Webtest2 is a great library for
testing web applications
for Python.
And it really makes sense to
use that in the App Engine
context as well.
DANNY HERMES: Is this a best
practice for our Python
developers for their
local testing?
Or is it just something that
we are big fans of?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: You
mean using webtest?
We are a big fan of it.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
We're not going to
make you use it.
But--
OK.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: It
makes it really easy.
DANNY HERMES: So is there some
reason the import of webtest
happened after the definition
of the class?
Or that's just--
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Oh, this
is really just-- so it's--
DANNY HERMES: Just
thrown together.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: --focus.
DANNY HERMES: Gotcha.
OK, great.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
So you know what--
DANNY HERMES: So it's not that
it's just thrown together.
It's important that you
draw your eye to.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: It
was intentional.
DANNY HERMES: Got it.
That's why you broke
PEP8, huh?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Yeah.
And I don't run Pylot here.
So what we do now--
DANNY HERMES: We don't
run Pylot here.
All right.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
On this demo code.
We do it at Google.
DANNY HERMES: Yes.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: OK,
so now that we have--
DANNY HERMES: So [INAUDIBLE]
your code everyone.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Now that we
have the app, we're going
to wrap it in a test app that
is provided by webtest.
So we say, webtest or test
app, please wrap this.
And this test wrapper allows
us to easily make requests
like get posts-- whatever
we want.
So in this example, we say
testapp.get, which is making a
get request to the app and
will give us a response.
The response object is also a
webtest [? wrapper ?] object.
And this one allows us to easily
query this status code,
the body, or the content
type, for example.
So the three things we
want to check for
our very simple handler.
And that's basically it.
So if we--
we can also, for example, just
copy this, and we'll make this
a post request.
And then just say hey, instead
of get, do post.
So it works the same way.
DANNY HERMES: Or we could set a
header and check that, also?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: You can
do whatever you want.
And something you often do on
App Engine is use App Engine
services, like you use Memcache,
for example, when
you want to retrieve
your stuff faster.
So how do we merge the two
tests things here--
the webtest and service
testing?
So the testbed thing we
talked about earlier.
Well, again, a simple handler
that would just, on a post
request, parse the key and the
value from the URL parameters
and put them into Memcache,
[? some other thing ?]
big here.
And the test now uses testbed
again, what we had before.
And before we also
used Memcache.
And we just do the same
thing we saw before.
We create an app in the
testbed wrapper.
Then we instantiate testbed
and initialize
the Memcache stub.
And for tearDown, we're just
going to deactivate it.
So what we do now in the test,
we say this is the key, and
this is the value.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
And we're going to pass
this to the handler.
And then the test itself checks,
hey, if I [? query ?]
Memcache now, is the key set
and does it return a value
[? assigned ?]?
So straightforward.
DANNY HERMES: So first
we saw services only.
Then we saw webtest only.
Now we see both of them used
at the same time, which is
probably what most of your web
apps are going to look like.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Yes,
most web apps use
some App Engine services.
OK, yeah, that's pretty much
what testbed allows you to do.
So it allows you to
write unit tests.
And unit tests really--
the greatest benefit is that
they run fast, or that they
should run fast.
So you can run them whenever
you save or whenever you
commit code.
And you get instant feedback,
which is a good segue into the
second type of test, end-to-end
test, which allow
large tests.
They test the whole stack,
from top to bottom.
And because of that, they're
really slow and they take a
while to set up, and then
also a while to execute.
But it's so important to do
end-to-end tests because while
you may trust the units, you
don't know whether the whole
setup will work, whether the
whole configuration, wiring
you have done, actually
is correct.
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: And part
of App Engine for--
AMY UNRUH: Robert?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Yes?
AMY UNRUH: Sorry to
derail you there.
I thought before we moved on
from testbed, one thing that
might be of interest to a lot of
people, because I see a lot
of questions about this, is
testing with HRD when you have
issues of the eventual
consistency.
Would you be willing to
say a few words of
advice about that?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: So like
a particular issue
I should talk about.
So one thing I can mention,
but you I think
you know, on the--
AMY UNRUH: People might know.
There's a setting to
indicate this.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: If you go
to the website, [INAUDIBLE]
world, describes [? to ?] you
exactly what you need to do.
So here you say, hey, we're
going to use the PseudoRandom
HRD Consistency Policy.
And if you enable that in your
tests, your tests will
actually work with HRD
similar behavior.
So that is not consistent
by the way.
You have some certain
random [INAUDIBLE]--
DANNY HERMES: It stimulates
the network latency,
effectively.
AMY UNRUH: And you can turn
that on for some tests and
turn it off for others.
DANNY HERMES: Also people who
are testing their apps just by
running them and playing around
with them by clicking,
keep in mind, dev app server by
default right now is still
master-slave.
So you're going to have to pass
in a flag to actually
make it be HRD when you're
just running
your development server.
And that's also something that
people don't always know,
don't always realize.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Yeah,
any other questions?
OK, then I'm going to go back
to the end-to-end tests--
and hope I find where
my directory is.
So end-to-end tests--
as I mentioned, you want to
test the whole stack.
And to test the whole stack,
you need to run the
application in some way.
An example is you have app.yaml
configured and say
this handler should work on
this path, and this path
should be treated
by this handler.
And this is something you cannot
test in the unit test.
You want to check that your
app.yaml configuration
actually is working.
So for this, you have to
run your application.
So one thing you can do is start
your application with
dev app server and
start clicking.
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Hey,
is this thing working?
Which is--
DANNY HERMES: it's hard to
automate your finger.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
Insidious, right?
You can have one of
those click--
I don't know what they're
called-- sipping birds, right?
DANNY HERMES: You can also use
something like Selenium.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: You could
use something like Selenium
web driver.
But you still need something
that starts up your app.
And in order to automate
that, there's a
library called gaedriver.
And gaedriver basically
does exactly that.
It takes an application and some
other configuration input
and says, now based on that,
we'll start your app with dev
app server, or we'll deploy
it to App Engine.
And this can be done
with an API.
So it can be part of
your test setup.
So you say, hey, please deploy
this app and then run the
following tests.
And this is what I'm going
to demonstrate now.
Let me see, I need to set
up the path again.
So let's look at the
app at first.
The app is just the standard
app.yaml main.
And it also has a static
directory, which just has a
static file, nothing special.
And then what we also have in
here is the configuration file
we're going to use for
this test run, main.
And this one includes
the app ID.
So if you want to deploy, the
library needs to know
where to put it.
And it also needs an SDK so
it can actually deploy it.
It also knows where the
application is located.
And in this case, cluster host
name is set to local host,
which the library will take as,
OK, use dev app server to
run the tests.
If you use appspot.com, it
will deploy the app to
appspot.com.
And in that case, you would
also need credentials.
DANNY HERMES: And I'm assuming
that it's going to parse the
port from this and pass it
into dev app server--
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Yes.
DANNY HERMES: --when
it runs it?
OK, cool.
So let's look at the
test module.
Here we have, again, unit tests,
some unit test library
and then gaedriver, which
library we use, and then the
config file I just showed, which
has the crucial config
information.
Two things we're going
to do here.
We will work with an app token,
which is something
gaedriver will give you to
shut down the app again.
For example, when you
started with dev app
server, it's started.
But you need some way to tear it
down, otherwise the process
keeps running.
So you need to close
it appropriately.
And then a config object, which
is basically the config
file parsed and then given to
you as an object so you can
use it in--
DANNY HERMES: The config
file in app--
excuse me, the config
file in app.yaml?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: The
gaedriver config file we just
[INAUDIBLE].
DANNY HERMES: Oh, OK.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
The app ID--
DANNY HERMES: OK.
Gotcha.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: And
cluster hose name
and things like that.
Because enter-enters are
expensive, you only want to do
the setup once, or
as few times as
possible, as necessary.
And for this we use setUpClass,
which tells the
unittest runner only do that
once per testclass.
So if we have five test
[? members ?] in the class, it
will still only do it once.
And we're saying for
tearDown class.
So what are we do here?
At first, we retrieve
the config object.
So we read basically the config
file and then have an
object that contains all
the information.
DANNY HERMES: This setUpClass
method, this
is not part of unittest.
This is some extension
of unittest--
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: No, it's
actually unittest.
DANNY HERMES: Wow, great.
So what you're doing, you're
making a custom test case.
And unittest--
well, unittest.TestCase and
unittest2.TestCase both
support this, having a class
method called setUpClass?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Unittest2
supports it.
Since unittest2 is part of
Python 2.7, you can assume
Python supports it.
DANNY HERMES: Right,
right, right.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: OK?
Good.
So in the second step, in the
setUp classes, just gaedriver
setUp app, and based on the
cluster host name, which we
have set to local host, it will
start the app dev app
server and then return
to the control flow.
And that's pretty much all you
need to do to set up your
application for testing.
And then let's look at one of
the tests here, test_homepage,
where you build the URL from
the config object, in this
case config.app_hostname,
would tell you, OK,
local host port 8080.
For when you deploy your
app, it would be the
foo.appspot.com
So you build your URL, then you
make a request to it, and
you just check the
response, whether
it's what you expected.
And if we look at the
application, hello world, and
this is what we want
to see, and the
same for dynamic content.
Oh and then, sorry, forgot to
mention that this test also
checks ETag headers.
ETag headers are HTTP headers
that are set to indicate to a
client, cache this content
or don't cache it.
And if it has an ETag header,
it will actually cache it.
And for dynamic content, like
what is generated with a
handler, App Engine will not
send an ETag header, because
dynamic content is generated
dynamically, so you don't want
anyone to cache it.
On the other hand, if you have
static content like whatever
you serve--
DANNY HERMES: Static.txt
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Yes.
App Engine will set an
ETag header for you.
And then a browser queries
it once, fetches it once.
And for the second request,
it would just
reshow the same file.
And here we just check that.
We build the URL again, make a
request, and check whether the
ETag header's in the response
and the same for the static
content where we actually
expect it.
And let's run it.
DANNY HERMES: Now you said
it's going to take a long
time, yeah?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Well, let's
see how long it takes.
DANNY HERMES: Obviously, longer
than 0.0051 seconds?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
Definitely.
Longer than the past.
But we're done.
So it took five seconds.
Five seconds to start the app
dev app server, make the
request, and then tear down
dev app server again.
For appspot.com it will take
longer because deployments
usually take longer.
So that's end-to-end testing.
And this is something we also
use as part of the App Engine
development, because one thing
we want to test is that all
the APIs work on the
entire stack.
So we have, for example,
applications built from tests
from Memcache.
So we check, OK, if I use
Memcache, does it go all the
way through to the Memcache
back-end, come back and have
the correct response?
So this is part of what we use
internally, but then open
source because it's useful
to others as well.
DANNY HERMES: Now, is there some
equivalent search term in
your favorite search engine for
gaedriver, like there was
for webtest?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: The search
term is basically gaedriver,
which will bring you to a Google
project code page.
And if you want to install it on
your machine, you can just
do a pip install gaedriver--
DANNY HERMES: From PyPI.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: --which
will fetch it.
OK.
And yes, since this is an API,
it's easy to integrate that
into continuous test
setUps you have.
Because I saw a question
on the--
DANNY HERMES: Moderator--
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
--Moderator page.
DANNY HERMES: --about
continuous
deployments and testing.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: So you could
use gaedriver for that
to say, OK, deploy
the app, run your
tests, see if it works.
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: OK.
And then that brings me to the
last part, which is library
testing, where we also want to
support developers who write
libraries for App Engine that
are then used for App Engine
applications.
and--
DANNY HERMES: NDB is actually
a good case for this, right,
because it started outside
and then made it in.
But it's still an
ext, so maybe--
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: But it's
a nice development model, I
think, because it allows you
to get feedback quick from
users, which is what
you really want.
So let's see where we are.
So for this, I'm going to use
a library called aeta.
Aeta also started out as
an internal project.
And this summer our intern,
Jacob Taylor, actually
polished it and made it an
open source project.
So again, you can
just search it--
aeta App Engine.
DANNY HERMES: What's
the acronym for it?
Or is this something else?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: It's App
Engine Test Appendix.
DANNY HERMES: OK, appendix,
appendix, got it.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: And the
name came from Guido.
So I just wanted
[? to do that. ?]
DANNY HERMES: A benevolent
name.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Yes.
OK, let's look at this.
Again, we have an app here.
In this app, app.yaml,
main.py.
And it then has a
tests directory.
And it includes the
aeta library.
So if we look at app.yaml, we
see whatever comes to tests/
is handled by aeta.
And if we look at the tests
directory, we just see a bunch
of tests there, fail tests,
for instance.
And now, let's start this
app and see what
it would look like.
So the app, the app itself
doesn't tell anything, but it
knows where the tests is.
So it points you there.
And this is now handled
by aeta.
And aeta will go through the
tests directory and look for
all the tests.
So this is a list of all
the tests it found.
This is the package.
This is the test module, and
then it found those tests
classes with those
test methods.
And then it allows
you to run them.
And we would just basically
say run them all.
DANNY HERMES: And are these
happening asynchronous via
HTTP calls?
They're not some sub-process
running on App Engine or
anything like that?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Oh, this
one-- so what happens this
front-end on the website talks
to the handler from aeta and
says, give me all the tests.
And then it responses
to all the tests.
DANNY HERMES: And then
it renders it
based on what it receives.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Yes.
So it's kind of AJAX-y.
DANNY HERMES: Yes--
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
And then we saw--
DANNY HERMES: --kind
of, kind of.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: --one test
that failed, which is
test_fail, which is expected
because it even says so.
DANNY HERMES: Cool.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: OK, and all
you need to do to use aeta
is basically go to, let's see,
aeta.googlecode.com, which
describes how to use aeta and
all that stuff, and put it in
your app directory, set up
app.yaml, and then set up a
test directory.
DANNY HERMES: It's
not yet on PyPI
ready to be pip installed?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: No.
DANNY HERMES: Someday, huh?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
It will be.
And one thing that's also useful
in the context of aeta,
you don't want to, again, go
to a website, click on
something, pass the
test results.
It's manual, expensive, and just
like a drag basically.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to start the
application on dev app
server, and then--
oh, that's small--
we can use a local client.
And this local client takes
just a URL, test--
I think it was this one.
And then go to the
aeta handler and
then query all the--
let me just see what's--
tests, OK, wrong path.
So it's going to work.
This should work--
goes to the aeta handler and
then queries, say, give me all
the tests and then we'll
run all the tests.
And why do we want this
in this wrapper?
Because we want to test code
within an App Engine
environment.
So we want to test it within
either the app server
[? environment, ?]
so the production environment,
or within the SDK.
Also--
OK, that failed.
DANNY HERMES: Maybe you need to
be super user or something?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Let's see.
DANNY HERMES: That's not
a hammer for every
nail, by the way.
I'm just postulating there.
AMY UNRUH: Maybe--
I'm sorry.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: It
just said local.
DANNY HERMES: There we go.
Typo.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Typo.
And so now we know,
OK, it passed.
And you can put this together
with gaedriver to start your
app automatically.
And then use aeta, the local
client, to run the test.
DANNY HERMES: So you're running
it from the main
directory of this application.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Yeah.
DANNY HERMES: So where does
local client come from?
It comes distributed
with aeta?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Yeah,
it comes with aeta.
It's a local standalone
client.
DANNY HERMES: OK, so is there
a reason it's at the root of
the directory, rather than--
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Oh, no.
Oh, actually it's not the
root of the directory.
It's just random.
We're actually outside
of the directory.
DANNY HERMES: I see.
OK, I got ya.
Just so you just put it so it
was below the application, so
you could actually hit the
application or what?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: So the
application, the local client
has nothing to do with the
application or with a--
DANNY HERMES: I realize this.
I'm just curious about why we
didn't just go into the aeta
directory in the application
to run local client?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Probably
what you--
DANNY HERMES: Semantics,
folks.
Really irrelevant but--
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: What you
will do at some point is--
and what our test setup also
looks like is-- we have a
bunch of unit tests.
We put them in an app wrapper,
then deploy those apps with an
automated script, based on
gaedriver, run the tests with
the local client, and then
integrate the feedback into
our test framework.
So it's really totally separate
from the app.
And one thing we also do is
we test it with different
environments.
So we use it to test it
against Python 2.5
environment, Python
2.7, different
dev app server setups.
So yeah, this is basically
where we use aeta.
And those are the three things
I wanted to talk about.
DANNY HERMES: Super helpful
demos, right?
If nothing else, just seeing
them all together and seeing
the quick mocks you can make.
It's pretty big.
As you could tell with some
of my questions, Robert's
test_foo is completely superior
to my test_foo, even
though I consider myself to be
something of a Python nut.
But these things are actually
pretty important if you have a
production application, and
you're running a business off
of it, which hopefully plenty
of people watching are.
So Amy, what next?
What else are we going to do?
AMY UNRUH: So thanks
so much, Robert.
That was great.
And if you're like me and put
off writing your tests until
the end of your app building,
maybe this will inspire you,
because you can see how easy
it is and how great some of
this stuff is.
So I think we've got a few more
questions coming in on
the Moderator that
are test related.
So I want to apologize in
advance to the few questions
that are not test related, which
I think we might need to
get to next time.
We'll propagate them along.
Let's see.
So we've covered the
one about webapp2.
And you sort of covered
this one.
But I'll let you answer it
further if you want to.
For functional tests, is there
any recommended setup--
BDD, Selenium, any built-in
feature in
App Engine for this?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: There's
no built-in feature in App
Engine, because, like the
webtest library we use to do
handler testing, there are
really great open source
projects to do functional
testing, so [? drive ?]
[? your ?]
[? website ?], for example.
My personal preference
is WebDriver.
It has a great API.
And it allows you to
use different types
of browsers as well.
And if you use, for example,
gaedriver, you can start your
app or deploy it and then
integrate that with the
WebDriver test that hits certain
URLs, certain elements
on the page and then
checks the output.
DANNY HERMES: It's a bit
of a tough question.
We certainly want to help
people with this.
But a lot of the things we're
providing are server side.
And when you're talking about
testing JavaScript and user
interfaces and things like, it
starts to leave the scope.
I guess if you're talking about
things like the channel
API, it's always within our
scope and things like that.
But it's hard to try to
cover all of this.
But like he said, it's something
that we're aware of.
And we certainly use.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: So there are
really great resources but
because it's much bigger
than App Engine.
It's really web testing,
right--
web application testing-- which
you can write on Tomcat,
or whatever you want, right?
We don't cover it
in particular.
DANNY HERMES: Sorry.
AMY UNRUH: OK, here's
another one.
And again, you've touched
on it a bit.
How do you set up your test
environments, especially CI
with a packaging format that
App Engine is delivered in?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: I'm
not sure I quite
understand the question.
What's CI?
AMY UNRUH: So Continuous
Integration.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: So what we
do as part of App Engine is
also we have applications that
are checked in and then we
use, for example, gaedriver
to, whenever there's
a change, run them.
For example, with the SDK,
run all the tests like
WebDriver-based tests and then
see whether they still pass.
And the same you should be doing
probably both for the
SDK, but also before
you deploy.
Because the SDK tries to be as
close as possible to the
production environment, but
it's not quite there.
DANNY HERMES: It's
not equivalent.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: It's not
equivalent, but close.
So it really makes sense--
and we do the same--
to test our applications both
on the SDK and in the
production environment by using
tools like gaedriver to
deploy them automatically with
an API and by using tools like
WebDriver to do the functional
testing.
And since those have APIs, it's
easy to write scripts
that do that for you, so
you can automate it.
DANNY HERMES: Also, I guess
the second part of this
question asked about
the packaging.
But as we saw with things like
gaedriver, you can actually
deal with that in your
config file.
So it's something that as long
as you're putting it in the
same place, or as long as you
know where you put it, you'll
to be able to set that
in your config.
Next question?
Anything else?
AMY UNRUH: That is actually
the last testing-related
question, although I'll briefly
address one that's
easy to address.
Are there plans for a Dart
runtime environment?
So this, I'm afraid, is our
stock answer, that we can't
comment on things that aren't
on the roadmap.
Sorry about that.
DANNY HERMES: I can answer more
questions [? if you ?]
can't comment, if you want.
[LAUGHING]
AMY UNRUH: Well, it's been
sitting there for a while.
And there's also a good question
about Eclipse, that
we hope to--
we've been having Python-heavy
Hangouts recently.
So we hope to have some
in the future that
focus more on Java.
So I think we'll propagate that
discussion question to an
upcoming Hangout, since we're
running a bit short of time.
Robert, if people were
interested in getting this
code, just to play around with
it, would it be easy to make
it available to people?
I mean, would it be easy to
give it to me, and I could
work on making it available?
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES:
We can do that.
Also, gaedriver and aeta
both have demo apps
that come with them.
So once you download those
libraries, you can
just work with them.
AMY UNRUH: OK, that's
probably sufficient.
DANNY HERMES: Are there wikis
on these projects?
If not, then I would be
happy to write it up.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Just, again,
go to the aeta project
page and the gaedriver page.
They also have stuff.
DANNY HERMES: And they've
got wikis.
Awesome.
Great.
AMY UNRUH: OK, great.
Thanks so much.
DANNY HERMES: Go
forth and test.
AMY UNRUH: It's really
wonderful.
All right, see everyone
next time.
We'll have another one next
week, another Hangout.
So watch for the announcement
on that.
DANNY HERMES: Thanks,
everyone.
ROBERT SCHUPPENIES: Bye.